An adult film star,
a media executive,
a fixer all tied to Donald Trump no matter who you are.
We cannot and will not normalize serious criminal
conduct.
Newly unsealed court documents lay out how a web of key players were involved in the events
that led to the former president being charged with 34 felony counts of falsifying business records.
Trump has pleaded not guilty.
The only crime that I have committed is to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it.
Here's a list of who's who in this historic case.
Adult Film Star Stormy Daniels met Trump in 2006 at a Celebrity Golf Tournament where
she said he invited her to his hotel room and you had sex with him.
You were 27 he was 60.
Were you physically attracted to him?
No,
Daniels tried to sell the story of her alleged sexual encounter with Trump to media outlets multiple
times.
According to court documents annotated by the Wall Street journal,
former Trump fixer Michael Cohen covertly paid $130,000 to Daniels
shortly before the election to prevent her from publicizing a sexual encounter with Trump
Cohen,
who served as Trump's personal lawyer at the time was a key witness before the grand jury that indicted
the former president.
Court documents say after the election,
Trump reimbursed Cohen for the illegal payment through a series of monthly checks.
Cohen was sentenced to three years in prison in 2018 after pleading guilty to nine
federal criminal counts including one related to his payment to Daniels.
Mr Trump directed me to use my own personal funds from a home equity
line of credit to avoid any money being traced back
to him that could negatively impact his campaign.
Alan Weisberg,
the long time Chief Financial Officer of the Trump organization facilitated Cohen's reimbursement for the
payment to Daniels.
According to Cohen and federal prosecutors in order to be able to
put it on to the books,
Alan Weisberg made the decision that it should be paid over the
12 months so that it would look like a retainer.
Weisberg hasn't commented publicly about the matter.
He pleaded guilty in an unrelated state tax fraud case and was sentenced to five months in
jail.
Earlier this year,
Weisberg discussed reimbursement for another hush money payment made in 2016 by David ***.
According to Cohen and prosecutors,
*** is the former Chief Executive of American Media Incorporated,
Publisher of the National Enquirer and appeared twice before the grand jury.
Court documents say he agreed to help with Trump's campaign saying that he would act as the eyes and
ears for the campaign by looking out for negative stories about Trump and alerting Cohen before the
stories were published In August 2016,
he bought and killed the story of former Playboy model Karen McDougall who alleged that she had an
affair with Trump in 2006.
The court documents say Ami ultimately paid $150,000 to McDougall
in exchange for her agreement not to speak about the alleged sexual relationship.
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg,
who took office in January of last year brought charges against Trump despite his predecessor deciding
not to Bragg alleges that the former president repeatedly violated New York's business records
laws in trying to cover up these payments.
The charge requires as I as I specified
criminal conduct that was concealed one of the concealed crimes we allege
is New York State election law In the
coming months,
a trial date will be set which lawyers and legal specialists have said could be pushed out a year or
more putting it squarely in the 2024 campaign season.